all right all right
hmm
smith's like oh god i can find a better
spot is it a reflection or something or
is it
okay what's your eyesight like summer
2020 okay sure
all right we are going to begin
uh good morning everyone we are right at
the end
of everything in proof we actually did p
1.1 which strictly speaking
that's what was called the nature of
proof that's where we introduced all the
weird language about statements
implications negations uh converses
contrapositives and so on
and then we just subtly slided into p
1.2
which was further mathematical induction
so we carried on
from last year's extension one induction
and then we found ourselves in
harder territory and that's what we've
been doing for the last little bit
now one of the tricky things that mrs
lisa and i have been um wrestling with
is this is one of those topics where we
could just spend
forever on it because there's just more
and more examples
to do and they will feel sometimes quite
different to each other even though they
all share the same dna they're all about
mathematical induction so i'm going to
put you through some resources
at the end of this lesson to help you
keep on going like you're like i want
more examples i want more like we don't
have the time
to spend it here um because we want to
move on to the 3d vector world but
you should keep on chipping away at it
and i would advise this is one of those
topics where
rather than a very concerted i just
spent like three weeks and just
do all of it and then forget about it
for a few months until
my next big assessment i think is a
really good thing to regularly just
every couple of weeks in term two and
term three just do one question
of mathematical induction just to
refresh your memory
but as promised we're gonna do this last
part of induction and you might be
looking
at this title thinking what is a first
order recursive
formula how is it different to like the
rebellions recursive
formulas that was a star wars joke too
early for you okay let's have a look at
what each of these means i'm going to
start right in the middle here
recursion any software design students
in here by any chance
one okay that's all right you know what
recursion is or at least you've
experienced it before
the rest of you maybe not formally but
you actually have got a very
um there's a very famous example of
recursion that you all know about and
i'd love you to write it down here with
me
it's this object i wonder if you can
help me know what this thing is it has a
name it is the
come on it's too early for bad star wars
jokes but it's not too early for this
right tell me what it is
this is the fibonacci sequence right
now this is a it's a very simple object
you could um
teach a very young child what this thing
is
um and how to get the next number which
is by the way
21 thank you now here's the important
thing how did you know
the next number was 21 how indeed did i
know what all of the previous numbers
were how did you recognize
and the answer is there's a very simple
formula
that gives you this sequence of numbers
if you want
for example the nth fibonacci number
like say the 99th fibonacci number
how do you calculate it
careful jeff the sum of the biggest two
it's the sum of
the sum of the previous two fibonacci
numbers so
the one before the nth one is the n
minus one fibonacci number
so there's the one before and then the
one before that would be the
n minus tooth fibonacci
number so you're like okay i get how to
form this and that's why
you said if i wanted what's this one two
three four five six seven
eight if you wanted the eighth one
that's why you added up the
sixth and seventh ones okay now the
thing i want you to notice about this
formula
is that it refers to itself so that
makes sense
it's like hey if you want to know what
this is you've got to know what me from
the past looked like right
and this is what we mean by recursion
it's a formula that refers to earlier
versions of itself
now this is a recursive formula it's not
just
it's not actually the kind we're
interested in today this is called a
second
order recursive formula so we're not
going to deal with ones this hard
the reason why it's second order you
might be able to tell just by looking at
how it's written
is that you have to look one step back
and then you have to look
a second step back two steps back
means it's a second order recursive
formula you could come up with a third
degree
recursive formula sorry third order
you'd have to go three steps back right
we're only going to look at ones where
to know what your current term is you
just have to look one back
right or to work out the next one you
can just go one step forward
okay so that's what the first order part
means
uh more technically speaking what we
mean is the difference
in term between the highest and the
lowest ones
is just going to be one okay so
colloquially i would say
only needs one
term previous
okay now we've actually been dealing
with a few of these formulas within the
course
within the advanced course in fact not
even extension one we're going to come
to one of those as our second example
but as our first example let me give you
one that's
fairly straightforward i want to come up
with a sequence
whereby if you want to work out what the
next sequence is
you look at the previous one
and then you add double whatever step
you are up to
okay so to work out the next sequence uh
sorry the next
term in the sequence um you look at your
current one and then you add on this
particular figure
you also need to know like with the
fibonacci sequence like with any
recursive
sequence you need to know where to begin
right so in other words we need
a t zero t
sub zero if we define the first term as
term one rather than term zero now
what's the next term
it's going to be t2 equals
2 plus now it's 4 isn't it that gives me
6.
is that okay let's do the next one
term three is going to be this plus
six which is going to give me 12.
next one's going to be 20.
so you can see my gaps right four and
then six
and then eight and then ten okay dot
dot this makes you feel better all right
let's do our
proof by induction all in one go we're
gonna test
base case is n equals two we're gonna
assume it for n equals k
and then you might think mr you haven't
left very much space in your proof step
well
just watch what's about to unfold all
right we actually already
did this but let's uh let's give it a go
term two
i'm going to establish it first from the
formula that i know
and then i'm going to test it with this
formula that's unproven that's my job to
prove is that okay
so term 2 from the formula that i know
is going to be
term 1 plus 2 lots of 2 which
already worked out for me earlier is six
okay
this unproven formula uh so i'm going to
use
i'm gonna actually give this a name
let's call this one
using one i can find t2 in a more direct
way without relying on what t1
was and it's just going to be n squared
plus
n which gives me 6 like before okay
maybe one thing that might have been
helpful to write earlier on is that this
is from the recursive formula
so i might even jot that down from the
recursive formula
because i've got two expressions here
for t2 but they come from different
places
and then i've just named this particular
equation down here i'm just call it
equation one
all right we're back on track now we do
our assumptions so i'm going to assume
that this actually does work
for n equals k so i'll just substitute
in
k squared plus k and of course
the same limitations or domain
restrictions on n
act on k as well so i will say 4k is
greater than one
so far so good i've left way too much
space for my assumed step i should know
better
all right now we're going to prove
for k plus 1. all right now remember the
recursive formula is the bit that we
know
that bit's established okay this is the
thing
we need to prove what's it equal
for the k plus one step help me out
i'll give you a clue it starts with some
brackets
k plus one i'm going to square that
because that
is my substitution into n and then on
the end i add
k plus 1. i'm going to be a little lazy
and go one step further i think i can
expand this because it will make the
algebra easier for me to search for
k squared plus 2k plus 1
coming up first and then there's going
to be some like terms
to collect how many k's will i have
three three of them
what's my constant two happy times
this is where i want to arrive
that's my goal how do i do it proof
this is going to be one of the shortest
proofs by induction you ever do and you
have done some short ones i think
remember this is where we're trying to
head but what we can use as a foundation
is the recursive formula right like
that's the thing which is our foundation
and is established
so i'm going to say from the recursive
formula
i can get at this k plus 1
term from a different angle right from
the recursive formula the k plus
plus one term should be equal to
have a look if i put in k plus 1 into
the recursive formula what's the first
thing that i get
t k it's really just to be you know long
about it
it's k plus one there's me substituting
in n
minus one is that okay make that
substitution super duper clear what do i
add along the end
two lots of k plus one
okay excellent now like you already told
me this is just
term k but i have an idea of what term k
is from my from my what from my
assumption right here
this is what i'm assuming term k is
actually equal to so i can say
well let's just let's just put this in k
squared plus k
and i still have this 2k plus 2 hanging
out at the end
you just invert the inductive hypothesis
so you should say
by assumption
okay wonderful now i promised it was
going to be a short proof right
are we kind of done wow
i hardly had to do anything now my
question for you is
why they sounded so weird and
intimidating and i even you know got my
wires crossed at the beginning
why is it do you think that proof by
induction is the
perfect way to deal with first order
recursive formulas
do you want to have a stabbing yet it
kind of reminded me of the domino
um analogy in what way does this remind
you of domino's
no the analogy that they use for
induction yep if the previous one works
and the next one works so
since these um recursive formulas
on the previous one yeah so it's kind of
similar yeah yeah
i'd say that's a really good job were
you thinking along similar lines or
different ones
yeah i'd say so i think that's perfect
actually think about it this way right
first order recursive formulas are all
about looking one step back right and
relying on that
proof by induction is all about looking
one step forward and then
making a conclusion from that you're
really looking at the same problem
just from opposite angles that's why
they kind of very nicely dumped out
together